cowbells are important
for swiss culture it's been
hundreds of years comedy bell at
vhc traditions so in friborg there
are about four games per
inhabitant that means it represents
about 250 thousand cows and then we can
already hear the chainsaw  other
writings at the doors
wonderful
and skype and history the spy kenneth
[Music]
my name is stéphane brut lumière
makes bells for cows we
put bells or cows to
find them in a fog when they
are in the Alps
I make  bells for thirty
two years I started with my father the
one who showed me everything from the port
so in Switzerland there are eight people
making tramps so for me
it's clear it's a satisfaction in
the last
[  Music]
for the manufacture of a cowbell
they make a model we first make the
outer part of the eighth note and then
we make the inner part of the
bell
these parts sound  t assembled and after we
can cast the bronze was
afterwards we can customize them according to
the wishes of a client
[Music]
on cowbells in principle I
always put the Swiss cross a chalet
a cow and 2 and grease
[Music]  ]
per year I make about 2000 2500
bells not me the cowbells
group at 150 francs up to 4000 francs
we have the state the small bells this
rather does not burn the pastures and after
the big bell it is for the best
of  cows don't make something with
my hands I find that it's great
she morning you arrive at a pile of
sand evening to have ten
bells who are this fabulous
[Music]